as previously rumored microsoft  confirmed that they are working on a  higher powered model of the xbox one  called project scorpio set to release  next year the system will feature 8  cores 320 gigabytes of memory bandwidth  and 6 teraflops of performance to allow  for fully uncompressed 4k gaming that  seems to suggest it will not simply be  upscaled 2160p microsoft added that the  console would also be capable of  targeting 60 frames per second and we'll  deliver a no-compromise experience for  Spencer is said that the xbox one xbox  one s and project Scorpio will all be  completely compatible with one another  and share all games and accessories no  pricing information has arrived as yet  so updates on this one and everything  else that matters in gaming and be sure  to check back to gamespot